dans les rues d'autun vincent chauvet
vient saluer ses sympathisants
rencontrés dans le centre ville pourtant
en mars dernier les autunois ne l'ont
pas porté en haut des suffrages au
premier tour la liste du maire sortant
est arrivé qu'en deuxième position
derrière celle de frédéric brochot un
coup dur que vincent chauvet tente de
minimiser
j'ai fait un bon score nous sommes
quasiment à égalité dans un premier tour
très particulier où très peu d'électeurs
se sont déplacés
comme dans beaucoup de villes de france
et donc de nombreuses personnes n'ont
pas pu s'exprimer et les résultats sont
à prendre avec des pincettes en tête au
premier tour
frédéric brochot sa liste a créé la
surprise à autun pour espérer l'emporter
le vice président du département peut
compter sur le ralliement de bertrand
joli 3e au scrutin de mars dernier
je salue déjà la décision cohérente de
bertrand joly de m'apporter son soutien
une décision bien sûr qu'il a prise avec
la majeure partie de ses colistiers
on se retrouve sur beaucoup de points
dans mon programme
il m'apporte son soutien sans aucune
tractation avec moins de 7% des
suffrages obtenus au premier tour
impossible de dire si ce soutien aidera
frédéric brochot à creuser l'écart avec
le maire sortant ce qui fera peut-être
la différence celle influence des
personnalités politiques autour de
chacun des candidats
frédéric brochot est très proche du
président du conseil départemental andré
accary vincent chauvet lui et le dauphin
du député rémy rebeyrotte est soutenu
par le parti au pouvoir
la république en marche chacun de ces
cercles d'influencé n'a pas la même
vision du futur pour autun notamment
pour le musée rolin actuellement objet
de fouilles préventives
j'ai obtenu de l'état et de la région
plus de 8 millions d'euros
de subventions pour réaliser ce projet
qui consistera dans la rénovation de la
prison panoptique dans la création d'un
belvédère à 360 pour que les touristes
puissent voir à la fois la cathédrale et
le morvan et puis on va doubler la
surface d'exposition assez de doubler le
nombre de visiteurs ça va ramener des
touristes à autun frédéric brochot
préfère soutenir le futur parc
historique qui sera implantée à tournus
un projet porté par le conseil
départemental
- j'ai pris des engagements avec le
promoteur et avec eux bien sûr mon
président accary qu' il y a une liaison
forte un lien fort entre ce futur parc
de tournus et la ville d'autun avec
toute sa richesse
augustodunum donc c'est un consensus ce
parc drainera sur l'ensemble du
département
mais avec un lien très fort pour la
ville d'autun la vie politique a
toujours été tumultueuse à autun
l'édition 2020 ne devrait pas déroger à
la règle